c'est quoi votre programme a réuni
présent sur l'économique votre programme
c'est quoi mon programme économique
s'est déjà des délais gilet jaune
comment ces gens en ville avec 800 euros
par mois nous est fermé on dort on dort
dans des droits de soi on peut enfin
mauvaise et et détruire détruire
détruire l'économie parisienne donné au
gie les jeunes ce qui leur doit donner
l'heure une augmentation arrêtons
arrêtons ce drame
mais tout ça fleure afida c'est une
blague voir votre candidature ou bien
vraiment vous pensé aller au bout nicole
oui l'été l'île s'ils vous savez à qui
vous avez affaire jeune blake j'avais on
a 300 me twitté 300 villages et même est
sympa présidente je je j'aimerais
apporter mon soutien à ces gourous
journal au gilet jaune
comment appuie là où pensez que vous
pouvez peser sur la prochaine élection
vous savez mon prix est incommensurable
cyril hanouna et vous savez oui mais
alors à remonter sa volonté incroyable
qu'est ce que j'aimerais aider le
vainqueur français surtout les gilet
jaune
comment on laisse une économie française
détruites
quand finalement peu juste sur donner
une augmentation à ses ouvriers ces gens
comment voulez vous avez journaliste à
la tribune très bon soir les tribunes de
boulettes mais elle ne comprend pas
l'anglais par le caractère non juste une
question puisque vous dites que vous
voulez aller au bout de ma candidature
n'est pas une farce et que vraiment vous
avez vous sembler être extrêmement
investi il faut il cire il l'a dit un
parrainage est faux il faut donc prendre
son bâton de pèlerin venir en france
elle frappait aux portes des maires et
les convaincre chacun chacun de ces
mères là les convaincre alors développer
leurs programmes et le programme et en
disant voilà je vous demande de me
paraît n'est pas ce que je voudrais que
vous appuyez ma candidature comme qu'est
ce que vous allez dire à ces mères quand
vous allez les voir la france pour
qu'ils appuient votre candidature qu'est
ce que vous leur direz au delà des
généralités parce qu'on est tous
d'accord
évidemment qu'on veut tous être que que
les plus faibles soient soient mieux
rémunérés qui soit mieux protégé que ça
ira mais comment qu'est-ce que qu'est ce
que vous proposez concrètement oui
valérie je vais vraiment on dirait c'est
à dire qu'avec trois cent mille euros
2,8 et 300000 ac
j'aimerais juste en fait de pouvoir
aider les gens vous comprenez
dire que la vérité et les fans et le
public est roi
moi je suis une femme du public je suis
né orpheline je me bats tous les jours
de 10h
comprenez moi ya pas une fille de
rachida et le pain le peuple le
souverain pour ça non adhérents je serai
pas président mais en tout cas je
pourrais apporter ça fait drôlement mon
aide aux gens qui ont besoin on prenait
et valérie vous allez vous avez vous
également revenir avec moi à oui dans la
rue manif les jambes parce que vous vous
posez la question vous devez tenir
également vous devez supporter par les
eaux claires